When you picture a unicorn,
what comes to mind?
A white horse with
a gleaming horn,
maybe a shaggy rhinoceros,
a terrifying horned rabbit
or a multicolored chimera?
The tragic news is that only
one of these creatures is real
but the good news is that
all of them are unicorns.
Before unicorns were cemented
as the universal symbol
of purity and grace
we picture today,
they were a whole malleable
class of folklore creatures
who shared a single trait:
that solitary horn
erupting from their head.
Most of the modern
unicorn's predecessors
had dark dispositions
and body parts borrowed
from multiple beasts,
likely inspired by
real-world animal anatomy.
Thus hidden in the
mythology of the unicorn
is a lesson in how humans
collective imagination
can adapt truth into whatever
fable we need at the time.
[inquisitive music]
Since time immemorial,
one-horned creatures
have prowled our dreams
and nightmares alike,
but they didn't
spring fully formed
from myths or fairy tales.
Instead, we find powerful
unicorns in natural histories,
travel logs, and geography
from around the world.
For this reason, many
unicorns straddle the boundary
between fact and fiction.
And that only becomes
more obvious when we look
at how they've been translated
across different cultures.
While some one-horned
creatures influenced the figure
of the white equine unicorn
that became popular in
the Western imagination,
they also complicate
its symbolism.
Rather than denoting
purity or chastity,
the unicorns we'll
talk about today
are hybrid creatures
with multifaceted powers.
The millennials in
the audience know
who "The Last Unicorn" is
but one of the first
is the bovine unicorn
of the Indus Valley
civilization in South Asia.
Described as a bull, ox ,or
an antelope of heavy build
with a horn protruding
from the back of its head.
It's been found on official
seals dating to 2,600 BCE.
Figurines of this creature
have also been found
across ancient India,
Pakistan, and Mesopotamia.
Some scholars have linked these
stocky single-horned figures
to the very real elasmotherium,
a giant rhinoceros
that had already
been extinct for eons
and whose fossils could have
inspired the unicorn myth.
Whatever the inspiration,
the Indus unicorn was
usually shown beside
a stand of sacred water
or other offerings
indicating that this
is no ordinary animal.
Another exceptional creature
continues this trend
of fusing zoology and
mythology, the Chinese qilin.
It's described as having
the body of a deer or elk,
the tail of an ox
and a single horn,
but also shows up
covered in scales
and surrounded by
fire like a dragon.
Qilin were known for
their gentle disposition,
and as tokens of good luck
with their appearance
often heralding
the birth of an
important person.
While some accounts
picture the qilin
as a supernatural figure
who clomps across the earth
without disturbing
a single blade of grass,
they also made
their way into real life.
In 1414, the Ming emperor
was presented with a qilin
from a far away land
only to discover
that what he really had on
his hands was a giraffe.
Amalgamations of mythical
and real animals
continue in the karkadann
which appears in
Islamic writing and art.
Described by polymath al-Biruni
as a scaly buffalo with yellow
hooves and a horned nose,
scholars generally agree
that he was talking
about rhinos here,
but embellishments
and mistranslations
produce karkadanns
as winged antelopes,
horses,
and even feline figures.
Others fuse different animals.
In one account, the karkadann
sports the head of a camel,
body of a mule, and the
tail and hooves of a bull.
In another, it's a giant
elephant horse mashup.
The karkadanns horn was also
the source of much debate.
The medieval geographer
Muhammed al-Idrisi tells us
that it's so big you can't
fit both your hands around it.
While the naturalist
al-Damiri insists
that the horn is so heavy
the karkadann can't even
hold its own head up.
In all their forms,
karkadanns were fearsome.
They were said to
actively hunt humans
or to inflict death on
all who heard their voice.
It also has a fraught
relationship with other animals.
In one story, the karkadann
takes out its mortal enemy,
the elephant, by impaling
the elephant so deeply
that it can't extract its horn.
This story tends to end
in pretty grizzly ways
with all the elephant's
fat seeping out
and blinding the
karkadann, for instance,
or a huge bird carrying
both animals to her nest
and feeding them to her chicks.
These stories convey the
brutality of the animal realm
which the karkadann
appeared to rule over,
but never with
absolute security.
In comparison to
other Islamic unicorns
the shadhavar seems
deceptively benign.
This deer-like animal
sprouts hollow branches
from its single horn
which makes sweet music as
the wind whistles through them
but the music ultimately
attracts unsuspecting animals
who are promptly devoured
by the wily shadhavar.
These dangerous tendencies
don't stop people
from coveting their horns.
So-called karkadann horns,
whose original owner
was usually a rhino,
was sold as a remedy
for countless illnesses.
It was said that a karkadann
horn could also be used
to heat cold water,
ward off evil forces,
and keep horses
standing upright.
In one Persian legend,
karkadann horn
is mixed with dust
and sprinkled over
a band of robbers,
immobilizing them before
they can ransack a village.
These Middle Eastern unicorns
look very different
from each other,
but are united by their rarity,
ferocity, and unpredictability.
Descriptions of these
creatures reveal the overlap
between myth and observation
in that they tend to
embellish the animal realm
and heighten the chaos
of the natural world.
Early Western ideas about
what the unicorn looked like
echo this embellishment,
but they also stemmed
from confusion and intrigue
about exotic, faraway creatures.
In a tangled zoological
and geographical
report of "The East,"
the Greek physician Ctesias
reported Indian unicorns
with crimson heads,
multi-colored horns,
and shapely ankles.
He also notes their
blood-thirsty violent nature.
Pliny wrote of monokeroses,
meaning single horn,
who each had a stag's
head, elephant's feet,
a boar's tail, and
a single black horn.
While Claudius Aelianus
described a red-haired horse
with a curly pigtail
and spiraling horn.
These creatures have
been variously linked
to the Indian rhino,
the Tibetan antelope
and the onager, or kiang,
both a type of donkey.
But Europeans had their
own take on the unicorn
throughout the early
Christian and Medieval period.
Christian writers
linked unicorns
and their mystical powers
to Jesus Christ himself
or a symbol of the cross.
The unicorn was thought
to have kept Adam and Eve
Company in the Garden of Eden
cementing its status
as supreme animal
and a spiritual allegory.
So as unicorns were absorbed
into Christian iconography,
they became associated with
purity, chastity, and unity.
There's a clear distinction
between the pure,
angelic unicorn
and its hybrid
fearsome predecessors.
Recently, the unicorn has
earned a third reputation
as we in the queer community
have claimed its wild
side for ourselves.
There are plenty
of glittery horns
and flowing rainbow manes
in queer iconography
but the connection
goes deeper than that.
In queer culture,
unicorns are celebrated
as creatures that
shun the status quo
while reminding us how
special and resilient we are.
We have adopted the unicorn
as slang and symbol,
empowering ourselves
and our queer kin
to embrace our identities.
LGBTQ+ soldiers fighting
in Ukraine's army
have started sewing
unicorn patches
onto their uniforms as a way
to express pride, solidarity
and the desire to be seen.
Here we see echoes of older
and more varied
understandings of the unicorn
whose power lies in
its outsider status,
its hybridity and its
resistance to classification.
Ultimately, it's this
lack of consensus
that gives unicorns
their symbolic power.
As creatures who muddy the
line between fact and fiction,
disrupt cultural boundaries,
and reveal fears and fantasies
about the natural world,
unicorns have always been about
subjective interpretation.
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.